this man who's getting sent for another
college football season on behalf on
behalf of Fox Sports and the athletic
great to see our friend Bruce Feldman
how are you sir well what is the story
going into this season do you think for
college football right around the corner
well story is are we gonna get another
Clemson in Alabama fine I mean let's
that's the elephant in the room
literally so if I think there's a lot of
fans who are like anything but that you
know right now I think people have seen
what Clemson is done I look both
quarterbacks to at Alabama Trevor
Lawrence we had a phenomenal first
season they're back all the skill guys
are back to at the exception of you know
Alabama lost a great running back in the
draft but they were so deep there anyway
and once again clemson lost its entire
defensive line in the first round of an
NFL draft so we'll see how that works
but they got guys there who I know might
be first rounders to come in I know
exactly right so and if you look at it
both teams have really really manageable
schedules the rest of the ACC is pretty
down Syracuse is gun on the rise I'll
give you that but you look at the
non-conference of Alabama when Duke is
the best of your four opponents and this
isn't gonna be daniel Jones Duke this is
probably gonna be five and seven Duke
that's a an indictment of what you got
the rest how is that allowable I'm
serious you know obviously when you come
out with a schedule a school that
eventually when they come to your spot
or you have to go to theirs
isn't as good as they were when you
schedule them I get it but you know we
had David Shaw on yesterday you know
he's got Northwestern USC with all you
know due respect to the top pac-12 I get
it he's got Notre Dame I mean Notre Dame
but I'm talking about in just the first
four weeks what I'm saying the first
four weeks I read off Stanford's first
four weeks he's got a tougher first four
weeks than maybe you could say Alabama
has the entire year you know we our crew
actually has that Stanford northwestern
opener it's a 23 versus 25 matchup I
think the part where you can pick apart
and look I've had this conversation with
David Shaw in the offseason before where
there is no real uniformity the
conference he's in plays three
non-conference games and when you play
Northwestern and Notre Dame you know
you're playing too legit programs
it's the the
ceci has four non-conference games and
almost always it's three cupcakes in one
manageable game and this time you know
look when you're alabama you're gonna be
favored against everybody anyway but
when you're playing duke as opposed to
let's say they schedule penn state or
they schedule wisconsin or even they you
know they schedule Oregon because Auburn
is playing Oregon and to start off the
season and it's not say
Alabama hasn't done in the past and they
do have some big games and now they're
gonna be home in homes a new ad there
Greg Byrne or relatively new ad has
pushed to upgrade those but getting back
to the David Shaw point there is no real
uniformity and when you're at the top of
the food chain and the SEC is that and
Alabama's certainly is that yes you pull
you play by the rules you can live by so
they're not getting 12,000 people
showing up if it's a really crappy
opponent they're gonna pack the stands
they may not stay there for four
quarters but they're gonna tune in
they're gonna do TV ratings it's all
works out for them and until the SCC if
it's a team that has a really bad
non-conference schedule and they don't
have much margin for error until the
conference the playoff committee holds
that against them but I can keeps them
out or uses that against them there's no
reason to change and I don't see any and
anytime that being used against Alabama
well save him something no and look in
fairness to Alabama they have earned the
benefit of the doubt I mean Nick Saban's
won national title after national title
when they've gone on the big stage and
Notre Dame fans won't like this but
they've gotten in there and last year
they got blown out by Clemson a few
years ago when I was before it was the
playoff committee they were on the big
stage and Alabama destroyed them
that wasn't even a game and so when you
get in those big games how you perform
in the in that playoff setting or in
those on that big stage even though it's
not supposed to factor into what the
playoff committee is talking about or
deliberating about it's it's a human
nature thing they're going to factor
into it Bruce Feldman here on the Rich
Eisen show and let's touch on Clemson I
know you mentioned Brockman's alma mater
and Syracuse we had Dino Babers callin
for his birthday
back in July that was fun
and just he's contagious I mean his is
personalized contagious and and at the
at the conference media gathering see
Ricky's got a couple of first-place
votes over Clemson I mean what do you
make of all of that I think he is a top
15 maybe top 10 coach if you look at
what Dino Babers has done in the three
places he's been right remember he was
the guy who got Jimmy Garoppolo cranked
up and a 1 double a school turn that
place round went to Bowling Green got
that place going in year 2 and then
Syracuse with all due respect sir q
service was god-awful and irrelevant I
mean it just kind of fallen off the
radar and by year 2 you know they upset
Clemson last year they win double-digit
games and what I think is really
interesting here is and I'm you know the
recruiting rankings there is a there is
a lot of correlation between how the
online recruiting sites rank you and and
what happens on the field not in the
case of Syracuse
they have had classes ranked an average
of 55th since Dino Babers has been there
but what he has done it's really smart
evaluations and really good player
development they've gotten a lot faster
a lot longer and they're really deep in
the secondary and they have a
quarterback who's gonna take over from
Eric Dungy named Tommy DeVito who was
probably the biggest recruit he's a New
Jersey kid biggest recruit Beiber's has
had I think they're a team that is
probably the second best team in the ACC
which granted isn't saying that much
after Clemson but I think they have a
chance to be a top 15 team and his name
is gonna be really really hot for some
big jobs if they're as good as I think
they are because of how well he's built
that team and also you watch a speech of
Dino Babers in the locker room he is a
dynamic speaker that's just know I know
what a price on that either and but he's
basically the only thing keeping from
Clemson getting into the college
football playoff is that what we're
talking about here because they play
week three so yeah well they have tech
yeah they have Texas A&M Texas A&M has
has talent Jimbo Fisher's done a good
job I don't think they'll win that game
but Texas A&M when it was at College
Station last year gave them all they
could handle and Kelly Bryant
you know the quarterback is now at
Missouri help them now let's get into
that cuz this may be silly season
conversation while we're waiting for the
comp for a college football season to
begin but the heat that has been at
least placed in the direction of Clemson
not likes Dabo Swinney with his hundred
million dollar contract or whatever he's
absurd he's making might deep down feel
it and and I don't think anybody
questions his connection with his
players that said he's gotten some heat
for not giving Bryant a championship
ring went clearly the kid did get some
crucial early season wins before he got
a problem with losing his job what do
you think yeah you know I can see both
parts of this because in the end he you
know he left and he had to do what's
best for himself and then by doing that
you know he wasn't with the team the
rest of the way and so if you're gonna
say well if you're not here for the
whole run that matters and you're trying
to if you're Dallas when you're a coach
you're trying to underscore the nature
of how important it is you know your
alma mater has a very very profound
statement from Bo Schembechler those who
stay will be champion correct I mean so
I get that now look a to Kellie Bryant's
credit I think today or yesterday he saw
that this had gotten I would say out of
hand in terms of the discussion and the
argument back and forth and he said look
this is an odyssey this is not a story I
get it by the way I think telly Brian
already has a national title ring from a
couple of years ago when Clemson want it
so I mean I respect that he's kind of
spoken out like that you know and it's
just one of these things that it's like
prime Internet fodder because it gets
very people get emotional and who knows
how you know what to make of it I I
don't think anybody there wanted to
become such a story that it's becoming
no I know that and it's you know go back
and forth between like if it's
professional III get it it's just like
you know sorry
uuuuu left and you never know when
you're gonna get your job back you left
but it is also college and he's a kid
and he needs to get his opportunity if
he wants to get to the NFL and he's not
gonna maybe get it
standing with as a helmet underneath his
arm everybody could see what Lawrence
looks like I mean you're not getting on
the field because I mean there's already
NFL fans who are saying my team should
start tanking for this kid right now I
mean so I could you're way to I could
see both sides yeah and it's like you
know if you want to say hey you know
what he could have said just give him a
national he's just give him a national
championship ring I mean is this like
giving trophies to everybody I don't you
know you can interpret it however you
know you emotionally want to I think
ideally if he did that it would be like
you know what I think some recruits who
would look at it and go okay that's a
that's a really you know
charitable is probably not the right
word to use but right for that and then
there's probably old coaches and people
who you know ascribe to setting a
culture and say no that's the wrong
message to send so I think it's one of
those things it's kind of the we're it's
a it's it's a college football or
coaching Ross as a Ross shot is that the
word that was uh you know the Rorschach
test Rorschach thank you no problem for
us on the energy exactly first it to you
see it and obviously there's different
interpretations of people looking at the
same story Bruce Feldman here on the
Rich Eisen show so but then again not
everyone's Jalen Hertz right so is it as
simple as okay Oklahoma with Lincoln
Riley that system Baker won the Heisman
Kyler won the Heisman I'm not saying
he's gonna win the Heisman but as it as
simple as he this kid you just plug them
in and Oklahoma's not gonna lose a step
or any steam I think they will lose a
little bit of a step the difference
between Jalen and the other two guys was
the other two guys had like an
incubation time where they had to sit
out they were there for more time to
acclimate and get timing with those
receivers right now the receivers are
terrific that's that's a big plus I mean
the group you lose Hollywood Brown who
was you know blow the top off of any
defense now they got a bunch of bigger
guys who are also really athletic to go
to go along with CD lamb the problem I
think is they have to replace the the
best kept secret are not so secret thing
that Oakland Oklahoma was they're all
like coach Bill beaten Bo did a
phenomenal job there the last few years
not just with with pass protection but
in the run game they have to replace
four offensive linemen I think the bar
is so high now because of what you just
said back-to-back Heisman winners guys
put up ridiculous numbers
I think Jalen Hurd's can be really
really good but I think to expect what
people are gonna expect it's almost like
Christian McCaffrey the year before he
came out put up an insane like Barry
Sanders record breaking a year and when
you do that it's almost impossible
because you need everything to fall in
line and I just don't think he'll get
that it would not at all surprise me if
the other quarterback in the big 12 Sam
Ehlinger is the one who became the
Heisman guy because I think Texas at
least offensively is set up to have a
huge year I'm looking forward to that a
couple more minutes left with Bruce
Feldman Fox Sports the athletic out here
in Los Angeles Beiber's you mentioned
would be a hot candidate for a big job
with that one of those jobs be right
here in Los Angeles I think if this
season plays out the way I think it will
I think they'd be foolish not to at
least consider him USC we're talking
yeah we're talking about a guy who is
from the west coast spent a lot of time
on the west coast dynamic personality
has proven it now three times that he
can put a big jolt inside of a program
really exciting brand of football I
would think he would have to be on the
radar now so why do you think USC season
might is not gonna go clay Hilton's why
look I think they'll be better than they
were last year which isn't saying much
over five and seven I think the arrival
of Graham Harrell who comes in and takes
over for Kliff Kingsbury who was here
for a month he's brought them an
identity they need it I think that will
probably win eight or nine games but
here's the upshot of this deal because
they have plenty of talent they don't
have like the Pete Carroll level town
but they got enough talent to be a top
15 team the problem I think is he could
have a really good year make a big
improvement go in nine or ten games I
just don't think that the USC leadership
and I suspect by the time this plays out
you know come middle of fall they
probably will have a new ad I believe I
think Lynn Swann the new president there
will say hey look we got to go in a
different directions there's been too
much bad stuff that has happened on Lynn
swans watch but when they get through
this even if a nine or ten win season I
just don't think the power brokers at
USC are going to go I'm convinced after
this
oh yeah clay Holton is the right guy for
this because I think there's a lot of
people there who felt like he shouldn't
have been the head coach when he hired
him and they definitely don't feel like
he should be the head coach now and it's
unfortunate but this is I think the bar
is gonna be so high that the schedule is
loaded the first six games I just don't
think they can get to it
well the issue also might be that nobody
knows who the real power brokers at USC
is right now because the football
program is not the biggest fish that
that's being fried on that campus right
now I mean there's a lot going on
downtown here in LA and we'll see how it
all plays out let's land on the Big Ten
every year sir I go through some sort of
excitement level certainly when I see my
alma mater top ten
sometimes even top five and then on
occasion doesn't work out that way and I
look at you sir you're one of the many
people out there right now that are
talking my Wolverines up why are you
doing that Bruce Velma two big reasons
yes one is I think they may have as good
an offensive line this year as anybody
in college football a lot back now they
do have to find out you know for the
guys back but it's it's really a deep
group and I think it's a talented group
you have a lot of guys who are I think
will be maybe not first first round guys
but high draft picks really talented
experienced group the other thing which
I think is even bigger is Josh Gattis
comes in he's the new offensive
coordinators a big gamble by Jim
Harbaugh first-time offensive
coordinator but he is a Joe Morehead
protege for people who don't know Joe
Morehead is he was the guy who went from
Fordham as the head coach James Franklin
brought him to Penn State and he really
I don't say saved James Franklin but
that was when the Penn State program
took off and what he brought was this
RPO system which you see all over the
place now not just in college football
but he was an early adapter of it but
what really he did was he instilled so
much confidence in a place that really
was kind of rutted in its own identity
it's not to say it's a bad thing that
was lying back or you or the way they
won but at the end of the day there was
kind of a listlessness nature of the
Penn State offense and he came in there
almost immediate
and flip that but also help staff say
Quan you know so so how does this
translate to what's going on with the
Wolverines cuz again Gaddis you said
it's it's it's a it's a gamble didn't
harm but like call him the day he did a
big story about this on the athletic
never interviewed him now he had trusted
a lot of people who had done the due
diligence of and Joe Moorhead is one of
them you know he had a big role in some
of the key play calls that they had at
Penn State in game-winning situations
everybody I talked to who work with Josh
goddess or was connected to him raved
about him but again I used the Joe
Morehead example because anybody's been
around Josh Gattis knows there is a edge
to him there is a charisma to him and
there's an overpowering confidence that
is there and when I talk to people
inside the program they said there was a
big difference in that persona of the
Michigan offense this spring and going
forward and I think that was lacking
because what happened in my opinion is
late in the year they were so good on
defense but they leaned on it so much
when things didn't go great
you know when they'd have either a
couple of players banged up or in the
ballgame that a couple guys who didn't
play and then that a few more banged up
and it was like the margin for error was
so small they just kind of folded cuz I
don't think they could do it offensively
they just didn't have that kind of
confidence or that chip I believe they
have it now now look until they beat the
archrival it it's all hot air right but
look at how the schedule sets up you
know they do have to go to Penn State at
night and that's gonna be rough
Wisconsin week three I mean I don't
think Wisconsin's gonna be as good as as
they were they still have Jonathan
Taylor but after that I think they're
gonna be a little take a step back from
where there were a couple years ago but
Notre Dame at Michigan Michigan State at
Michigan Ohio State and at Michigan I
think that I'm not saying they're
running the table but my prediction is
they're gonna come out of the Big Ten as
a Big Ten champs so Jim Harbaugh will
take a team in Indianapolis for the
first time of his tenure here I think he
will
yeah all right Chris you ready to go to
Indianapolis first week of December
absolutely I never thought I'd say that
but a long season see Bruce you just
don't don't do this to me
but you're just you can only you can
only you can have my reasons at least I
can defend it are not saying it's
definitely I wouldn't bet my house on it
at this point next year the head coach
of USC football clay Helton Dino Babers
Urban Meyer give me rank it for me so I
don't think it's gonna be clay Helton
I'm not sure and I guess full disclosure
I work at Fox I'm not convinced it's
gonna be urban I wouldn't be surprised
they made a run at don't you put another
Penn State guy right here I wouldn't be
another Penn State guy around here you
know yeah no I know I wouldn't be sure I
wouldn't be surprised they made around
the James Franklin Wow I mean I've said
that before but I just think that he's
another guy he did work wonders at Vandy
they're really good at Penn State I
think if you're if you're a USC I think
you got to consider guys like that
rather than say hey we're gonna take
somebody from the NFL there's never been
a college coach or a college head coach
Bruce thanks a call thanks for stopping
by I really appreciate it we are gonna
apparently when we come back get a phone
call from the man of the hour in
Cleveland Damon Shaheed Giuseppe we're
gonna get a call from him which we're
excited about good to see you sir Bruce
Feldman right here on the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app